that's amazing man good stuff I also
want to say this to my fans
Tiger belly fans yeah last week I said
hey let's play me in Russell yeah right
so I had 50 60 people are you winning
are you 5 points I just want to play
with you they don't I know I mean I've
been responding their things this and
that but step up your game you play
Russell no oh you know what it is no
it's a game I want you to play it ok I
want you to play me on it I don't really
play games but I will that's never been
said [ __ ] uh I mean I've played games
but I haven't really played in years
it's been a while yeah but you have
played games yeah yeah why is it that
you don't play video games um it's hard
for me to find one that I really like so
the last game that got really into was
Diablo 2 and so so that was and then
when Diablo 3 came out I haven't touched
it because I feel like if I do that my
career will disappear you know one of
those yeah so I just kind of stay away
from it unless I'm less is more we can I
am I
I truly believe I really truly believe
that of manifestation ok kalila am i
lazy ok do I do nothing
correct oh you know what I'm gonna say
that again I don't want to laugh who you
just didn't feel right don't you I'm
about to get emotional so don't even
smile ok but look at me but you're
smiling now there's some I so what I'm
saying is is that
but I I sit back and I visualize things
what does this have to do with playing
video games because he doesn't play
video games because he doesn't want to
feel like he's always working because he
wants to make it you want so he was the
product it takes away from his product
yeah productivity but I go the other way
I become unproductive to be productive
exactly so you just wait for [ __ ] to
fall on your lap yeah it's worked better
for me it has technically it has this
this year you said your biggest year
it's been my biggest year in the history
of my career III a lot of to this
podcast a lot of to there's a lot of
good is a word how do I say I give
homage to how much but I uh this has
been like the best years I think that
podcast has helped I think that I see it
every week but I um I think love helped
a lot and also last week I was on the
goddamn Comedy Jam where Toki Toki the
dumb-dumb did a little appearance lured
out my pianist but it was uh people
liked it
[Music]